religious freedom in order to
truly have religious freedom you need
limits
on what religious freedom is great
example of it
i was just reading the radio can i
news outlet you know reading about can i
alaska as one does
and i noticed
that at a government assembly meeting
in the kanai peninsula borough assembly
there was just an invocation given
by a satanist
so each year this is according to radio
can i a list of residents sign up to
give an invocation to the kanai
peninsula borough assembly meetings a
list that already is filled up for this
coming calendar year the policy states
that the assembly allows for an
invocation which could include a short
prayer or a solemnizing message to be
offered at the beginning of the meetings
for the benefit of the assembly to
accommodate the spiritual needs of
public officials
and for the past few years and just
happening again last tuesday
satanists are showing up
iris fontana signed up to give a satanic
temple invocation which several members
of the community objected to including
an assembly member who called upon
residents to silently stand strong in
prayer setting scripture from matthew 4
10. i'm not going to read the invocation
because i don't think satanists should
be
encouraged in our society
but
this is what's happening
it's religious freedom right
isn't that what religious freedom means
doesn't religious freedom mean
that the satanists should be allowed to
hail their dark lord and call upon the
devil to control this world
isn't it if we listen here listen here i
might not agree with what you say but
i'll defend of the death of your right
to say it i might not agree with hailing
satan prince of the underworld the
father of lies the the
embodiment of evil
but i will defend to your death that no
i won't i won't i'm not going to defend
that right i don't think you have that
right i don't think the founding fathers
understood satanic invocations
as being covered by religious liberty
i think that if
someone had shown up to the continental
congress to give a satanic invocation
not only would this not be applauded by
those liberal-minded founding fathers
probably they would go out and and
gather kindling for the stake that they
would burn that person at
certainly in earlier america they would
do that
we know i think we all know
that
whatever religious liberty means in
america
it does not mean satanists opening up
our government meetings so i think we
need to start from that if we want to
get back to any normal understanding of
what freedom means in america let's
start from there we know that
that satanists are not what our founding
fathers were talking about when they
talk about the blessings of liberty and
no establishment of religion and and the
various
other religious phrases that are used
within our founding documents okay so
then what does that mean for what
religious freedom actually is
in the united states tradition
in the united states tradition god is
referenced in our founding document the
declaration of independence the entire
country is predicated on the idea that
our creator
god has given us certain unalienable
rights
namely the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
not satan satan didn't give us those
rights
satan didn't create us as god
satan is the enemy of god he rebelled
against god and got shot down to hell
and
now he's being tormented for eternity
god is mentioned in many official united
states documents
god is on our money
in our money it says in god we trust
in our national
pledge of allegiance we say
one nation under god
our nation was founded even before the
the founding of the american republic
our whole country which dates back much
further was founded by extremely zealous
christians
it's a christian country
that means that if you if you do not
accept certain at least basic premises
of christianity if you do not go along
with certain basic elements at least
then you don't really have a place here
i'm not saying you got to be in daily
mass and receiving all the sacraments
i'm sure the founding fathers wouldn't
have said that either
but if you do not believe for instance
that
the good lord gives us certain rights
that we have a right to life that that
life is ordered toward pursuing liberty
and that that this is conducive toward
the pursuit of happiness if you don't
believe that then america doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense for you does
it
you certainly don't have a right to
undermine all of those things
liberty
cannot coherently be used to undermine
liberty
you don't have a first amendment right
for instance to destroy the first
amendment
right you don't that that doesn't make
any sense
for much of u.s history we've had
blasphemy laws
if you
if you blaspheme against god the
christian god you could be prosecuted
now we think that's unshocking
unbelievable so un-american no it's only
been considered un-american for the past
50 years or so
only since cultural revolutionaries
wheeled had a hostile takeover of our
political processes of the government
and kicked the bible out of schools
kicked prayer out of schools and kicked
christianity out of the public square
and exalted satanism
that literally exalted satanism in
multiple places okay
so
if if we want to restore some semblance
of american religious liberty
i think we got to realize that somewhere
we went off the track and we need to
stop tolerating freaking baphomet at
government assemblies this is not
complicated folks good grief if you find
yourself on the same side as a horned
demon
switch sides something's gone wrong it's
not going to end well for you
kamikoto makes great traditional
japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques from japan
kamikoto taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan they only use steel sourced from
mills in japan each blade is crafted
using techniques that have been honed
and perfected for centuries for
generations it makes a really great gift
i love these knives they look beautiful
they're presented in this lovely
beautiful ash wood box they're they're
great for
chopping up things in the kitchen
they're great for preparing dinner
they're great for scaring your
colleagues at the daily wire when you
get your set of kamikoto knives as well
well they've got a massive extended new
year sale and on top of that sale you
can get an additional 50 bucks off any
purchase you make with the discount code
knowles click the link below or go to
kamikodo.com
e s use knowlescanwlespro code knowles
kwles to save an extra 50 bucks today
treat yourself in in the kitchen to
these really terrific knives wonderful
great tradition you will thank me later
i'm so glad you like that clip that
makes me feel great that you liked it
you watched it now i hope you click the
like button i hope you i hope you like
maybe left me a comment but what i
really hope is
you ring the bell
that way you'll get the notifications we
can be together again and even if we
don't get the notifications for whatever
reason
youtube
uh you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe
leave a five star review
the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]